هذه الدوره لمجلس
وزراء الخارجيه لجامعه دول العربيه
التحضيري
للقمه
اصحاب السمو والمعالي وزراء
الخارجيه
معالي السيد الامينه العام لجامعه دول
العربيه
اصحاب السعاده
السيدات الفضليات
والساده الافاضل
يطيب لي في مستهل كلمتي هذه
ان اتوجه بالشكر الجزيل
الى اخي سمو الامير فيصل بن فرحان بن عبد
الله ال سعود
وزير خارجيه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الشقيقه
على حفاوه الاستقبال
وكرمي الضيافه
وسخاء العنايه
في بلاد الحرمين الشريفين
كما اود
ان اتوجه لسموه
بارقى ايات تقديرنا
وامتناننا على جهوده الحثيثه
الراميه لجمع كل شروط نجاح الدوره
الثانيه والثلاثين
لمجلس جامعه الدول العربيه
ولمدها
بانجع سبل الاستجابه
لتطلعات شعوبنا المشروعات
وطموحاتهم الثابته
كما اشكر
معالي الامين العام
لجامعه الدول العربيه
السيد احمد ابو الغيط
وسائر فريق الامانه العامه على تفانيهم
واتقانهم في الاعداد
الاجتماعنا اليوم
وللاشتماع المرتقب
لقاداتنا في غضون
يومين
بحول الله
ينعقد اجتماعنا اليوم
في ظرف اقليمي خاص
يعرف تطورات
نوعيه
سريعه
ومتسارعه
تستدعي مواصله العمل من اجل رص صفوفنا
وتوحيد كلمتنا
بغيه تجاوز العقبات
والتحديات التي تحول دون ضمان مكانه
تليق بامتنا العربيه
لا سيما في ظل الاختلالات التي
تطال منظومه العلاقات الدوليه القائمه
فالتحولات التي يشهدها العالم حاليا
وما تنبا به من بوادر اعاده تشكيل موازين
القوى يجب ان تستوقفنا
لتدارس
واستكشاف سبل التاقلم معها
والمساهمه كمجموعه موحده
في صياغه
ملامح منظومه علاقات دوليه
نريدها ان تكون مبنيه على اساس
السياده المتساويه للدول والامن المتكافئ
وتوازن المصالح والترابط المنصف
في ظل اوضاع كهاليه
تتطلع الجزائر الى قمه جده التي نعلق
عليها اغلى امالنا
كفرصه متجدده
وجب ان نواصل من خلالها
جهودنا وان نكثف من اجلها مساعينا لكسب
رهانات العمل العربي المشترك
واستكشاف افاقه الواعده
عبر تثمين ما يجمع الدول العربيه من
مقومات اصيله
وتحييد ما يفرقها من تجاذبات هامشيه
لقد وضعت الجزائر
تحت قياده الرئيس عبد المجيد تبون هذه
الاهداف في صلب اولويات
رئاستها الدوريه
وهي التي اخترت لما الشمل
عنواننا رئيسيا
ومقصدا نبيلا للقمه العربيه التي احتضنتها
شهر نوفمبر المنصرم
كما سعد بلادي
بكل ثبات وعزم واخلاص لخدمه مشاريعنا
وقضايانا عبر تجسيد ما افضت اليه لقاءات
قادتها من قرارات شديده ومتبصره
تصب في مصلحه كافه الدول والشعوب العربيه
من هذا المنطلق
ترحب الجزائر
ايما ترحيب
ببوادر تكريس هذا التوجه
الذي بدات تتجلى
ملامحه مع استئناف الجمهوريه العربيه
السوريه الشقيقه شغله مقعدها بمنظمتنا
والخطوات التي تم اتخاذها
لتطوير
وتقويه العلاقات العربيه السوريه
والمساهمه بشكل جماعي في حل الازمه في هذا
البلد الشقيق فضلا عن التقارب الحاصل في
العلاقات العربيه مع الجارتين تركيا
وايران
وفي نفس اجواء الانفراج نحيي
وندعك المؤشرات الايجابيه
للوصول الى حل مستدام للازمه في اليمن
الشقيق بما يحقق اراده وطموح الشعب اليمني
في استعاده امن بلاده واستقرارها
واذ نستبشر واذ نستبشر خيرا بكل صور هذه
الحركيه الايجابيه
التي تشهدها المنطقه العربيه
فاننا نامل ان تتواصل وتمتد
وتتعزز في سوره توافق عربي كامل للاركان
يسمح بتدارك ما يتوجب علينا
تداركه والعمل المستقبلا على احتواء
الازمات داخل البيت العربي بدل السماح
بتدوينها
وتعقيدها
وتشعب اطرافها داخليا وخارجيا
اصحاب السموم
والمعالي والسعاده
تمنيت ان اواصل كلمتي
بنفس النبره التفاؤليه
وانا اتطرق الان للتطورات
المتعلقه
بقضيتنا المركزيه
القضيه الفلسطينيه
غير ان ما يعانيه
اشقائنا الفلسطينيون
جراء ممارسات المحتله الاسرائيلي
واعتداءاته الاجراميه الممنهجه
ضد اخواننا في القدس المحتله
والضفه الغربيه
وقطاع غزه المحاصر
فضلا عن انسداد افاق مسار السلام في الشرق
الاوسط كلها
امور بقدر ما تحز في نفوسنا
فانها تستلزم منا
مضاعفه الجهود لفرض احترامي حقوق الشعب
الفلسطيني
وعلى راسها حقه في اقامه دولته المستقله
وعاصمتها القدس الشريف
لقد حرصنا في قمه الجزائر
على تثبيت القضيه الفلسطينيه
على راس
اولويات العمل للعربي المشترك
واكدنا على طابعها المركز
وعلى تمسكنا جميعا
بمبادره السلام العربيه لعام 2002
بكافه اركانها وضوابطها
وتحت الاشراف المباشر
لرئيس الجمهوريه السيد عبد المجيد تبون
تواصل الجزائر مساعيها
الراميه لتحقيق المصالحه الفلسطينيه
عبر مرافقه كافه الاطراف
نحو تجسيد الاستحقاقات الوطنيه
المدرجه في اعلان الجزائر للم الشم من اجل
تحقيق الوحده الوطنيه الفلسطينيه الذي وقع
بالجزائر الذي وقع بالجزائر بتاريخ 13
اكتوبر
2022 من قبل جميع الفصائل الفلسطينيه
وعلاوه على ذلك
وضمن تفعيل قرارات قمه الجزائر
تواصل بلادي
بالتنسيق مع جميع الاشقاء العرب
مساعيها الراميه لتمكين دوله فلسطين
من نيل المزيد من الاعترافات الدوليه
والحصول على العضويه الكامله في الامم
المتحده
اصحاب المعالي
اصحاب السمو اصحاب السعاده
ان مبعث قلقنا المتزايد
يكمن ايضا في تواصل الازمات السياسيه
والامنيه في بعض الاقطار العربيه الجريحه
وظهور بؤر توتر اخرى
تحرم
اشقائنا من نعمه الامن
والطمانينه
والاستقرار والرفاه
في هذا الاطار
يشكل التردي الخطير للوضع في السودان
الشقيق
بتداعياته الامنيه
والسياسيه والامنيه
مصدر انشغال كبير بالنسبه لنا
وامام هذا الوطن بادر رئيس الجمهوريه
السيد عبد المجيد تبون بصفته الرئيس
الدوري للقمه العربيه
بمساع لدى الامم المتحده
والاتحاد الافريقي ومنظمه الايجارات
لبلوره مبادره مشتركه تضمن وقفه الاقتتال
وحقن الدماء واطلاق عمليه عمليه عمليه
سياسيه شامله لحل الازمه
ومن هذا المنبر
واذن ثمن الجهود المخلصه
المبذوله من طرف المملكه العربيه السعوديه
على سبيل وقف الاقتتال
وكل ما تم تحقيقه في هذا المسار
اجدد
نداءنا للاشقاء في السودان من اجل الوقف
الفوري للاعمال العسكريه
والتحلي بروح المسؤوليه حفاظا على الارواح
والممتلكات
والانخراط في مفاوضات سياسيه تفضي الى حل
سلمي ينهي هذه الازمه الخطيره بصفه نهائيه
ودائمه
وفيما يخص
الازمه في ليبيا
اود ان اجدد التاكيد على قناعتنا الراسخه
ان عوده الاستقرار
لم تتم الا عبر مسار ليبي ليبي يشجع توافق
بين بنات وابناء هذا البلد الشقيق
للمضي قدما في تنظيم الانتخابات
البرلمانيه والرئاسيه
لانهاء الازمه بصفه نهائيه
وتحقيق طموح الشعب الليبي في بناء دوله
ديمقراطيه عصريه
ومما لا شك فيه ان مسعى في هذا المستوى من
الاهميه
والحساسيه
يقتضي الاحتكام الى العقل والعقلانيه
والتحلي بروح المسؤوليه نحو الوطن
واعلاء مصلحه ليبيا والليبيين فوق كفه
المصالح الضيقه الاخرى
ونعمل من الاخوه في لبنان
ونتمنى لهم من اعماق قلوبنا
ان يتوافقوا على حلول تنهي
حاله الانسداد السياسي الحالي عبر انتخاب
رئيس للجمهوريه
والتفرغ لمعالجه المشاكل الاقتصاديه
الخطيره التي تواجه هذا البلد الشقيق
تلبيه لحق شعبه في العيش في كنف الامن
والاستقرار والهناء
اصحاب السمو والمعالي والسعاده ان
اجتماعنا اليوم يعد فرصه مواتيه
للتاكيد على اهميه
وحتميه تسريع مسار اصلاح
وعصرنه وتعزيز العمل العربي المشترك
استجابه
للتحديات الجمه المافله امامنا
ومن الاهميه بمكان التذكير بان قمه
الجزائر
قد اعتمدت جمله من الاقتراحات التي تقدم
بها سياده رئيس الجمهوريه سيد عبد المجيد
تبون بغيت تفعيل دور جامعه الدول العربيه
في الوقايه من النزاعات وحلها
وتكريس البعد الشعبي في مشروعنا الجماعي
وتعزيز مكانه الشباب والابتكار في العمل
العربي المشترك
وما احوجنا اليوم لهذه الاصلاحات
لضمان
استغلال امثل
لمقومات التكامل الاقتصاديه التي حبل الله
بها اوطاننا
لبناء مستقبل افضل لنا جميعا
مقومات على كثرتها
وتنوعها لا تنتظر منا الا توفير بيئه بيئه
محفزه لتحقيق ما تنشده شعوبنا من تعاون
اقتصادي
وتنميه مستدامه ورخاء مشترك
وما اشد
حاجتنا اليوم
لتعزيز اواصر التعاون والتضامن خاصه ازاء
الدول العربيه التي تجتاز ظروفا اقتصاديه
صعبه
تستدعي من جميعا حبه ضامونيه وفق مختلف
الصيغ المتاحه ثنائيا ام جماعيا كما ان
الحاله الاستثنائيه التي يواجهها الاشقاء
في جيبوتي والصومال من جراء الجفاف الذي
يجتاح منطقه القرن الافريقي
تتطلب منا
اتخاذ تدابير عاجله لتفادي
كارثه انسانيه وشيكه
تلكم هي بعض الافكار التي وددت ان
اتقاسمها معكم اليوم في بدايه هذه الجلسه
حول اهم التطورات المتسارعه التي تشهدها
منطقتنا العربيه
وحول حصيله عملنا المشترك بين قمتي
الجزائر وجده
وقبل ان اختتم كلمتي
اود ان اتوجه اليكم جميعا
بجزيل الشكر
والعرفان على كل الدعم والتاييد الذي
لقيناه منكم خلال فتره الرئاسه الدوريه
للجزائر التي يتمنى ان تكون قد وفقت في
اداء مهامها
وتجسيد حرصنا الدائم على الدفاع عن قضايا
الامه العربيه وتطلعاتها
والان
استسمحكم ان ادعو اخي
سمو الامير فيصل بن فرحان بن عبد الله ال
سعود
وزير خارجيه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الشقيقه
لتسلم رئاسه المجلس
متمنيا له كاملا نجاح
وتمام التوفيق في اداء مهامه
ومعربا له في ذات السياق عن دعمنا التام
لرئاسه المملكه وان يقينا انها ستشكل محطه
عامه
لتكريس اسس التفاعل والتوافق والوحده في
خدمه مشروعنا الجماعي
وهو مشروع حضاري بامتياز شكرا على كرم
الاصغاء والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى
وبركاته
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات